Ça va ou quoi ? Bien ?
Ouais ça va ouais c'est cool ça va
Ok
T'as pas embrassé Lucie ?
Nan ben là j'ai pas eu le courage, bon voilà...
Je t'ai donné une technique infaillible pourtant.
Eh oui mais c'est quand même vachement impressionnant une femme enfin.
EH ! Pardon monsieur.
Ah tu dis pas pardon ? Ah le mec s'en branle !
Vas-y laisse tomber c'est un con, c'est pas grave.
Le mec s'en branle ! Oui je sais mais on m'a raconté une bonne blague hier tu vas voir
Ok
C'est une blague zoophile.
Ouais ?
C'est l'histoire d'un mec qui rentre dans un bar et euh...
Ben c'est tout !
Ah oui nan mais elle est connue.
Ouais.
Ouais nan mais tu la racontes bien.
Ouais ?
Ouais j'ai un peu raté quand même.
Non pas du tout, au moins t'es franc, ça c'est cool.
... Bonjour
Non mais il y a pas de ...
GO GO GO !
Bon, qu'est-ce qu'on a ?
On a deux individus parfaitement incontrôlable chef !
Ils ont été observé en train de discuter sans connexion
...
A aucun réseau social.
Depuis combien de temps on les a perdus ?
C'est là que ça ce gâte ... Plus de cinq minutes.
Bon alors voila ce qu'on va faire.
Vous allez suivre mes ordres et tout va bien ce passer.
Qu'est-ce qui ce passe putain franchement ?
J'ai pas le temps de jouer à ce petit jeu,
vous allez prendre vos téléphones portables DOUCEMENT sans faire aucun geste brusque.
Maintenant tweetez un truc.
Tweetez un truc ???
TWEETEZ UN TRUC PUTAIN DE BORDEL !!!
-Je ne me souviens plus de mon mot de passe.
-Alors moi j'ai supprimé l'appli.
OK la situation est plus grave que ce que je pensais.
Envoyez le e-sniper.
Ça c'était votre col chef.
Cible en joue
Prêt à distribuer.
Bon je vous laisse une dernière chance,
Prenez un selfie, qu'on en en finisse.
Alors, juste, qu'on en finisse avec quoi ?
Votre addiction à l'amitié non-virtuelle.
Quoi ??
Vous êtes des vrais potes quoi.
Ouais Ouais.
C'est vrai.
Ok, envoyez la notification.
*Notification*
*rire*
Ah il est fou celui là !
Je vais le mettre sur Facebook directement !
Bravo chef !
Ça c'est du bon boulot!
*s'éssouflent"
*Bruit de photo*